and today we're going to talk
about immunity
which is important especially at this
time of the year
so immunity is the resistance
to
resistance to
disease based on a prior exposure
based on prior exposure
and of course this is the principle
behind vaccination
so humans have been sort of
using the properties of the immune
system to prevent themselves from
getting
disease for centuries
one of the first very clear examples
of this is back in the 18th century with
the english physician
edward jenner and edward
jenner found out or came to the
realization
that farm hands
on farms specifically milk maids that
were exposed to a variant
of smallpox from cows which is known as
cow pox could become immune to smallpox
so cow pox is a less severe form
of the disease and
what jenner did was to take pustules
from uh individuals who had the cow pox
uh disease and inject them into an
eight-year-old
boy um and then infect that boy with
smallpox to show that the boy was
immune to smallpox after
having received the cowpox material
okay and so this is the first example of
the vaccine
and because the vaccine was derived from
basically uh someone with cow pox the
word vaccine is from the latin
root of vodka which is cow so
that's where the word vaccine comes from
okay
so today we're going to talk about the
systems that our bodies have
to fight disease and there are
several different levels of the immune
system
so i'm going to talk about two of them
so i'll talk about two levels
of immunity
the first i want to mention is the one
that we're all
just like born with which is known as
innate
immunity
bless you so
innate immunity immunity as the name
implies
is something that we are born with so
this is inborn
it also doesn't have a delay
in when it's activated right so if you
have an infection this is sort of the
first line of defense right there's an
immediate response
and that's the in the innate immune
system so this is immediate
here i'll put this down here it's
immediate
so one example is of an innate immune
responses
this is not in a body but ex vivo but
here you see a human neutrophil and
neutrophils are part of our innate
immune system
and neutrophils hunt and kill bacteria
right you see that neutrophil chasing
after that bacterium
and it's going for it it's really trying
to get it but that bacteria really wants
to get away but
got it okay right so that's these
neutrophils are part of the innate
immune system it's inborn it's immediate
and in addition the response of the
innate immune system
doesn't really change if you've been uh
exposed to an uh an infectious agent
prior
to uh the the
okay so this does not
does not change i'm using the greek
delta
for change does not change
with prior exposure
okay so it's sort of like a constant
surveillance mechanism in your body
that will go after foreign agents okay
now this is very different from the next
level of immunity
which is known as adaptive immune
immunity
and as the name adaptive immunity uh
implies this is a type of immunity that
does
change it adapts okay and this type of
immunity is acquired
so it's also known as acquired immunity
but it's acquired
with exposure to a foreign agent
okay so
this this involves a change in immunity
this
one does not but the innate immune
response is immediate
whereas adaptive immunity takes time
there's a delay so this is also delayed
it's also highly specific
okay so it's highly specific to the
foreign agents
that you are infected with
the innate immune system is less
specific it'll recognize
like things like bacteria but it won't
be able to necessarily
like distinguish between different types
of bacteria
um so this is more specific than the
innate immune system
this is why every year you have to get a
flu shot because the flu virus is
constantly changing
and our immune system is so specific
that unless we get
a new vaccination our bodies will not be
able to recognize it
okay so this is
so now i'm going to break down adaptive
immunity into two branches
one is known as humoral immunity
and humoral immunity is basically
protein-mediated
and the proteins that mediate this are
called antibodies
these antibodies are proteins
it's called humoral because the
antibodies can be secreted
into the fluids or humors of our body
which is basically the blood
okay so there's humoral immunity
the other type of adaptive immunity is
cell mediated
and one thing i want to point out that
the types of cells
that make an antibody are known as b
cells
what the b stands for isn't really
important but
one thing that's helpful is that these
cells mature
in the bone marrow and b
stands for bone marrow okay so you can
always remember where they mature
okay now cell mediated immunity
in contrast involves a different type of
cell
called a t cell and the t of t
cell stands for thymus because these
cells mature in the thymus
okay and i just want to point out
where these cells come from so
we talked about adult stem cells earlier
and
in this case these t and b lymphocytes
over here
are derived from a multi-potent
hematopoietic stem cell
which generates a whole bunch of
different types of cells
many of them are involved in the innate
immune response
but this common lymphoid progenitor over
here
gives rise to d t lymphocytes and b
lymphocytes
which are involved in uh adaptive
immunity
okay so it's not important that you
remember where what all these cells come
from or
or what they like what the tree is
but that that these cells arise from
a common progenitor cell okay so both
of these
branches of the adaptive immune system
have
what are known as antigen
receptors i'll abbreviate antigen ag
so they have antigen receptors
meaning that they have things on them
that recognize
specific antigens and antigens are
basically
things that result in an immune response
okay they could be proteins
antigens are
substances
that
activate the immune system
that's just immune system okay
another abbreviation that i'll use is
when i refer to an antibody
i'm going to abbreviate it a b
all right so we have these two branches
of the immune system
and they each have a type of antigen
receptor
so now i want to go through what these
different types of antigen receptors
look like
okay i'm going to start with the
the b cell antigen receptor
also known as the antibody
also known as an immunoglobulin
okay so another these are all synonymous
but you will see them in different
contexts immunoglobulin
is abbreviated ig
and what the the antibody looks like
structurally
it looks like this and i'll just draw it
out for you down here
so i'm drawing a lipid bilayer that
represents the plasma membrane
the outside of the cell is going to be
up so that's the exoplasm up here
the inside down here is the cytoplasm
and this would be a b cell then we're
talking about here i'm going to draw
just a segment of the b cell plasma
membrane
and the b the antibody can have a
transmembrane domain
that spans the plasma membrane
and then there are domains
and what i'm drawing here is a circle is
an ig domain so this is going to equal
an ig
domain
it's just a type of protein fold that is
modular
okay so you can see up on my diagram
here
right you see these like here there are
these two green segments labeled v and c
each of those is a single ig domain okay
it's just a modular fold
that is uh separate from the other part
of the protein
okay so here we have
a long this is one polypeptide chain
that has a transmembrane domain and is
inserted
into the plasma membrane the n-terminus
is here the c-terminus is down here
and each antibody protein has two
of these long
polypeptides and because they're the
longest part of the molecule
they're known as heavy chains so these
are the heavy chains
and each antibody protein is composed of
two
identical heavy chains okay so these are
identical
and they also there's another component
which is present up here
and this is a shorter polypeptide and
because it's shorter and smaller it's
known as the light chain
okay that's the light chain
okay so that's more or less what an
antibody looks like
the part of this antigen receptor that
recognizes the antigen
are the tips right here so this
is where the antigen binds
and it can bind on either this side or
this side
this this molecule is laterally
symmetric
one side is identical to the other okay
now the t cell receptor
looks different
and the t cell receptor has fewer names
it's just called the t
cell receptor or the tcr for short
and the t cell receptor is structurally
very different
so now i'm drawing here a t cell plasma
membrane
here's the plasma membrane the exoplasm
again
is up the cytoplasm is down
below this plasma membrane and the t
cell receptor has
two chains one is called alpha
and the other is beta and it has fewer
immunoglobulin
repeats so that you can see
you just have this sort of smaller
system
here where you have an alpha and a beta
chain and in this case
this region here recognizes the antigen
okay so basically the t cell receptor
the tip of it
interacts with the antigen
now the b cell receptor or the antibody
has different forms so let's talk about
the different forms
and these are shown up in my slide above
right so you see over here here's a
antibody that has a transmembrane domain
and is anchored in the plasma membrane
but there's another form that lacks that
transmembrane domain
and instead of being a an integral
membrane protein is instead
secreted into the blood okay
so the forms of the b-cell receptor are
both a membrane-bound form
which is initially how this antibody is
presented
but later on it can be secreted
and this often changes when there's an
infection
okay so once you
have a virus or bacteria in your system
then you get the b cell sort of pumping
out the secreted form of the antibody in
order to fight the infection
okay in contrast for the t cell receptor
for the t cell receptor there's only one
form which is the membrane bound form
okay so for t cell receptors it's
membrane only
okay another thing that differs between
these antigen ceptors
receptors is the types of antigens that
are recognized
so antibodies can recognize
all sorts of different molecules okay
they're they're very promiscuous
but they and a given antibody is not
promiscuous
a given antibody will recognize a very
specific
structure okay but the possibility for
antibodies that they
they can recognize small molecules
they can recognize proteins
they can recognize dna they can
recognize carbohydrates
you get the idea right they really can
recognize a whole
range of different types of molecules
okay in contrast
the t cell receptor is more restricted
and that t cell receptors will recognize
peptides or short sequences of amino
acids
so it recognizes peptides
and these peptides are presented to the
t
cell on a type of molecule
presented by the mhc
complex there are two classes
one and two and we're going to talk
about this
in detail in friday's lecture so i just
want to point out the difference
in the types of antigens that can be
recognized here
and we'll talk about exactly what i just
what that means
on friday
okay so now we have to talk about the
amazing
properties of the immune system the
first is how specific it is
it's specificity right and i think this
is a really amazing
property the ability to
really discriminate between very closely
related molecules
right and this is essential for immunity
to work well
right you want to recognize things that
are foreign agents
that have like invaded your system you
don't want to be recognizing
uh proteins and structures that are
natively present in your body
because if your immune system did that
you'd have an autoimmune disease
okay so the specificity is really
crucial
for the function of the immune system so
now i want to talk
how is it that the immune system
achieves such high levels of specificity
and the way i want to illustrate this is
i want to bring this down quickly
so if we consider the structure of the
antibody
um these different domains um
are different and in that and how
variable they are
so some are variable so this domain here
for the heavy chain
is the variable domain of the heavy
chain which i'll just abbreviate
vh and then these other immunoglobulin
domains are
constant meaning they don't have a lot
of variation
in sequence like the heavy chain
there's a variable domain for the light
chain which i'll abbreviate
vl and then there's a constant
domain for the light chain okay
and so what i want to do now is consider
what the sequence variation is here on
this antibody
this is the same over here right this is
the same
thing over here you have a variable
domain for the heavy chain and a
variable domain for the light
chain so let's consider
the amino acid sequence
of the antibody molecule specifically
at that variable part of the protein
so let's say we could take individual
antibodies
and define their sequence from n to c
terminus
that would be from tip towards the end
here so if we take
a number of different antibodies and a
line
align their amino acid sequence so what
i'm
i'm not writing out an amino acid
sequence but i'm just
illustrating like a particular type of
computational
experiment you could do so these would
be
aligned amino acid
sequences
where each of these represents a
different antibody let's say heavy chain
polypeptide
that's produced from a different b cell
okay
so each of these is a different
antibody from a unique b
cell
and then we just consider the residue
number
and how much each amino acid residue
varies
along this sequence okay
so if we were to align antibody gene
stretches like this and look at how much
variation there is
you'd get a graph that looks like this
okay
so the y-axis is the amount of variation
and the x-axis here is the residue
number along this polypeptide sequence
okay and what you see probably even
without
the color here is that there are these
three regions
where there's a lot of variation in the
sequence of different antibodies
okay so here you see the blue segment
here has a lot of variation the yellow
segment has a lot of variation
and the red segment here has possibly
the most variation
okay and what these are known as
are hypervariable regions
meaning that they exhibit a lot of
variation
another name for them is that they are
complementarity determining regions
complementarity complementarity
determining
determining
regions or cdrs
and there are three of them one two and
three okay
so there are regions in this antibody
molecule which are much more variable
than others okay so what are these
regions
well this is a sort of crystal structure
of the and of an antibody and you can
see how the antigen is bound at the end
right that would be this end of the
molecule or this end of the molecule
and here you see a ribbon diagram of the
structure of the antibody
and the complementary complementarity
determining regions
are the regions here that contact the
antigen
okay and what they are
are basically here's an ig fold this
whole thing
and there are the three loops that
extend
out of the end of this molecule and you
can think of them as three fingers
okay then these fingers are able to
reach out and sort of
grab on to like a foreign particle and
or any particle and stick to it
okay so
so these are the variable regions and
they have differences
in amino acids an amino acid sequence
and even very small differences
in the amino acid sequence
at this particular part of the of the
antibody
can have a huge effect on whether or not
they're able to stick to something right
you can imagine if i lost my thumb then
right now i'm not able to
sort of stick to that anymore okay so
small differences in amino acid sequence
result in large
changes in
the affinity of this antibody
for an antigen
okay and antibodies have different
sequences
meaning that they're able to bind to
um specific substances differently okay
so if an antibody has one set of
sequence it might
recognize one structure if it has
another sequence it might recognize
another structure
okay so just by changing the sequence
at these complementarity determining
regions has a huge
influence on what these proteins will
bind to
okay now each b
cell expresses a unique antibody
and just one unique antibody
so each b cell
in our body expresses
one and only one antibody protein
okay and that antibody protein has a
unique sequence at the cdr
region
and this one antibody has unique
specificity
for the for an antigen
okay so here you can see in my diagram
i have a whole bunch of b cells here
they all express
a different antibody and you can see
that the way you could get more of a
given antibody
is to clonally expand one of these cells
and all of the cells that result from
that clonal expansion
will express the exact same antibody
okay
okay and and when you have a clonal
population
of a cell that all has the same antibody
that's known as monoclonal
okay so each b cell will have a b cell
receptor or an antibody
with unique specificity so now the
question becomes
okay so i told you how you get
specificity
but in order to have a functioning
immune system you need to have
lots of different b cells that each
express a different
uh b cell receptor okay so there needs
to be a way
to generate diversity
and the answer to how we generate
diversity has an mit connection
the research wasn't done at mit
but the person who discovered the
mechanism is now
at mit on this research was performed by
susumu
tanegawa
and professor tanagawa for his work on
how this diversity is generated
was awarded the nobel prize in medicine
in 1987.
okay so professor tanagawa did this
research elsewhere but now he's a
faculty member
here at mit
all right so diversity the problem of
diversity right we have millions of b
cells that have a unique antibody okay
so one solution to this problem
would be we have a million different
antibody genes
and each b-cell clone sort of expresses
one of them
okay how many genes do we have
anyone know roughly on the order of
magnitude
do we have a million what's that
exactly yeah so mr george has suggested
miles i believe yeah okay good miles
suggested 30
000 which is like a good upper limit
right
so having a million antibody genes
sounds a little bit
unfeasible okay and so it's basically
unfeasible for us to express
as many antibody genes or have as many
antibody genes as we
have antibodies we just don't have
enough real estate in our genome
okay but there's another solution to
generate the diversity
which is essentially a form of shuffling
okay so we have a single
um heavy chain gene for antibodies
and we have two genes for the light
chain but
these genes are composed of multiple
gene
segments there are multiple gene
segments
specifically the segments that make up
that generate this variable domain okay
is composed of multiple gene segments
and these gene segments are shuffled
during the development of the b
the b cell to give rise to different
proteins
okay so these gene segments are shuffled
to generate this diversity
okay so now i'm showing you on the top
here
this is the human immunoglobulin heavy
chain locus here
you can see it's pretty big there are
lots of components
i want you to focus on this so
there's um you see in orange there's
this variable
gene segment and there are 45 variable
gene segments here
there's this diversity or d segment here
which there are 23 of
and then there are six of these joining
or j
segments okay so these are all distinct
parts
of the gene they're all distinct parts
of the exon
that encodes this variable region of the
antibody
okay
so you have multiple
v d and j
gene segments
and in order to generate a functional
antibody
one v has to be brought together with
one d
which has to be brought together with
one j for the heavy chain
okay so you have
multiple vd gene segments and they have
to be
brought together
to form a functional
antibody
okay that's illustrated right here so
here you see this is the light chain for
the light chain they're only in v
and j gene segments uh for the heavy
chain there's v
d and j and so
most of the cells in our body and the
cells of our germline the
very early stages of development all
have this arrangement where you have
everything still intact but during
lymphocyte development specifically in
lymphocytes
there's a recombination event that
brings together
v and j segments or v d and j segments
okay so this is mediated by
recombination
recombination at
the heavy and
light chain
genes for the antibody okay
and so this is very different from the
recombination we talked about earlier in
the semester
where recombination is happening during
meiosis and the formation of the gametes
right in that case recombination is
happening between homologous chromosomes
here we're not talking about
recombination between homologous
chromosomes
we're talking about recombination that
brings together
and deletes segments along a single
chromosome
to bring these v and j segments together
okay
so this is sort of an intrachromosomal
recombination
which deletes the intervening sequences
and brings these gene segments together
to form a functional
antibody protein so this process
is known as vdj recombination
and this is lymphocyte specific
okay and that's because during the
development of b and t
cells there's an induction of
uh recombinases that
mediate this recombination so
in this case there's a recombination
which is mediated by
recombination activating genes one and
two
called rag one and two okay
so there are these are lymphocyte
specific recombinases
which mediate this rearrangement which
bring together
unique v d and j segments together
okay so the diversity comes from the
fact
that each of these v d and j segments
each the
each v segment
you could all this also applies to d
segments and also j segments
has a unique sequence
so it encodes for a unique amino acid
sequence
meaning that if you bring together
different combinations
of these d's and j's you get a distinct
protein
okay now even if you had all the
combinations of vds and js
we you still don't have the diversity
that we see in the human body
so there's another process that further
generates diversity
which is the fact that when these
segments are getting shuffled
it's imprecise in that nucleotides can
be inserted
or deleted as these segments are joined
which generates greater amino acid
diversity
and this is called
it's called junctional imprecision
so this recombination is not precise
but it leads to the insertion
or deletion of nucleotides
of nucleotides
and if there's a multiple of three
nucleotides either inserted or deleted
then
you get a functional antibody why is it
that it has to be a multiple of three
jeremy otherwise you end up with a frame
shift exactly right this is
and the this is on the more sort of like
n-terminal side of the gene right so if
you inserted one nucleotide
between v and j then the downstream
portion of the gene the downstream part
of the open
open reading frame would be out of frame
and wouldn't generate a functional
protein
okay so it has to be a multiple of three
yeah georgia is um precision
specific or is it not it's just the rag
one and rag two
are turned on specifically in the
lymphocytes as they mature
and that also affects the insertion
pollution well if you don't have
recombination you can't get junctional
precision
right so the junctional imprecision or
junctional imprecision
the junctional imprecision is a
consequence of the recombination
process itself right so if you're not
having recombination
you're not having any junctional
imprecision because you're not
generating a junction
okay now there's one more thing that's
important here
which is something that happens
not as a consequence of this
recombination process
but as a consequence of activating the t
cell response which is that in addition
to these variations there's also
something known as somatic hypermutation
so there's an elevated mutation rate
at the ig locus that further
increases the diversity of the amino
acid sequence
at these variable regions of the
antibody okay
another way this is referred to is
because it can increase
the affinity of the antibody for
a antigen it's also known as affinity
maturation
so these are synonymous
maturation maturation
okay so and this depends on
the t cell the cell mediated branch of
adapted
immunity so this is t cell mediated
so one other aspect of this process
that i want to talk about is until this
recombination
happens the immunoglobulin gene
is not expressed so it's this
recombination
that leads to the expression of the
either the heavy chain or the light
chain gene okay
and that's because the enhancer is sort
of downstream in the gene
and by deleting the intervening sequence
here you bring the promoter
in range of the enhancer and now this
gene is expressed
okay but remember you have two copies of
each of these genes you have a parental
copy and a maternal copy
and another feature of this system is
that there's what is known as allelic
exclusion
so you the system is such that a b cell
expresses only one antibody
and so if you had both alleles
expressing that wouldn't be the case
okay so allelic exclusion makes it
that if you get a recombination event
that
leads to a functional antibody for one
of your
uh sort of inherited copies of the gene
one of your alleles
it suppresses recombination on the other
one
okay so you will only get one of these
genes
one heavy chain and one light chain
expressed per b
cell okay so only
one gene
expressed so that each b cell only has
one antibody
okay i just wanted to point out finally
that
these junctions between v d and j
segments
fall right in this cdr3 region so
they're responsible for the high level
variability at the cdr or hypervariable
three region
okay and because of the allelic
exclusion each b
cell expresses only one antibody
okay so all of the antibody proteins
expressed by that cell will be exactly
the same
okay so now the last property of the
immune system
we need to talk about is memory
and so the immune system the immune
system needs to be able to recall
past infectious agents that it's
experienced okay
and so it needs i guess we're kind of
personifying here but it needs some sort
of memory
right it needs to be the ability to
recall this
okay and this is the principle behind
vaccination right
the way vaccines work is to put in one
of these
attenuated or inactivated foreign agents
such that your body is able to remember
that later on when you get the real deal
and it's able to fight it off okay
so the body has to be able to remember
and several ways in which this manifests
itself
if we compare a primary infection the
first time you've seen an infectious
agent
versus a secondary infection they have
very different
responses from the standpoint
of the adaptive immune system okay
so if we consider the lag before your
adaptive immune system really takes off
the primary response takes about five to
ten days
so it's a bit delayed whereas the
secondary response can be one to three
days
okay so it's faster it's able to react
faster when you see an infectious agent
the second time
if we also just consider the magnitude
of the response
by considering how much antibody the
antibody concentration that's like put
into your
system then the primary response
is smaller and the magnitude of the
secondary response
is larger okay
so you basically your body is able to
produce more antibody against an
infectious
agent the second time it sees it not
only is the antibody
amount better the second time but
actually the
are antibodies themselves okay and we
can
show that by thinking about antibody
affinity
which is how tightly the antibody
recognizes the antigen
and i'll give you numbers that represent
the dissociatin
dissociation constant for an antibody
to a given antigen so the lower that
number is the tighter the binding
so for the primary infection
the antibody affinity is weaker
on the order of 10 to the negative 7th
molar
in terms of kd and this secondary
infection generates antibodies that are
functionally quite better they bind much
tighter
it can be less than 10 to the negative
11th molar
which is sub nanomolar right that's a
really tight
interaction between two molecules so the
antibodies
you get more of them and they're better
antibodies okay
so what makes this memorable
is that um when what lasts in your body
from the first time you see the agent to
the next
is there's a type of b cell known as a
memory b
cell
and this memory b cell will express
a given antibody and that antibody will
be specific
to the substance you saw previously and
because recombination is
this recombination is irreversible
then that b cell is going to remember
that antibody because it's still encoded
in the genome
so the the memory results from vdj
recombination being irreversible
and the fact that these memory b cells
stay in your body
even if the antigen is not present so
these also
stay in the body
okay so effective vaccines generate
these types of cells these memory b
cells okay that's important if you want
an effective vaccine
that you have these b cells that retain
information about the past infection
all right so what exactly is it that the
antibodies do
so i'll talk about effector functions
of antibodies
so antibodies can bind to
a foreign substance and interfere with
the normal function right if you have a
bacteria
and maybe the antibody binds to some
part of the bacteria to interfere with
that bacteria getting into the cell
okay and this type of effect is known as
neutralization
if you had an antibody that bound to
something like a bacteria
you could also have it recruit
phagocytic
cells to internalize that bacteria
and so you could also induce
phagocytosis
in addition antibodies when bound to a
foreign substance
if that foreign substance is a cell then
it could recruit
a killing cell to kill that cell
so there's also a killing aspect to this
okay so what's in this diagram here is
a type of cell known as a natural killer
cell
that is killing its target cell and so
you can kind of think of this cell
as the terminator okay so
right if the natural killer cell
recognizes this target here
then it's hasta la vista baby and that
cell is dead
okay i just want to point out
one thing that i mentioned before which
is
that antibodies can be leveraged to
generate treatments for certain types of
diseases
and we talked about a drug called
herceptin or not a drug but a it's an
antibody but it's a treatment
for her2 positive breast cancer
so this is used to treat her2 positive
breast cancer and it's really been a
a nice success story and uh the the
cancer
field because what this
what herceptin is it was derived from a
mouse antibody so this is a mouse
monoclonal antibody
that recognizes this her2 growth factor
receptor which is over expressed on the
30 percent of human breast cancers
and what herceptin is is that
researchers
took this mouse antibody and engineered
a human antibody to have the mouse
sequence
at its complementarity determining
regions
such that you have a human antibody that
won't be
sort of removed by the human immune
system
but will recognize her too and recruit
human immune cells to her two positive
cells
possibly killing those cells or binding
to her two and somehow
neutralizing the activity of her two on
these
cancer cells so antibodies can be very
useful for therapeutics
as well as being useful in our own
bodies to mediate immunity
okay we'll talk about t cells on friday
remember to bring your projects
you